salut pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
je m'appelle fabien olicard et sur cette
chaîne on parle de mentaliste mais aussi
de tout ce qui amène à réfléchir ou de
tout ce qu'on peut obtenir qu'on
réfléchisse aujourd'hui je vous donne 5
astuces pour mieux gérer votre argent et
peut-être même en gagner mais aussi à ce
titre qui vous a peut-être par une un
peu plus tactique et pas du tout puisque
à la fin de cette vidéo je vais vous
révéler combien je gagne sur youtube
je vais commenter pour ceux qui suivent
quotidiennement la chaîne les mantallot
sachez que demain la vidéo du calendrier
de l'avent sortir un petit peu plus tard
à 21h le temps que celle ci existe et
qu'elle ne se croise pas trop premières
astuces pour mieux gérer son argent il
faut évidemment suivre c'est quand ça
paraît évident j'enfonce une porte
ouverte je reste de courir grand montant
important c'est la base aucune des
quatre astuces que je vous donnais par
la suite ne pourrait fonctionner si déjà
de base vous ne suivez pas votre argent
et ça on le sait c'est pas simple c'est
très lourd de gérer son argent au
quotidien d'aller consulter ses comptes
aussi relevé bancaire d'anticiper les
dépenses futures de vérifier que tout ce
qui le rend très bien rentrés etc etc
c'est aussi essentiel que ces rôles ou à
faire j'aimerais solution pour cette
astuce là qui fonctionne très bien c'est
une application avec qui je suis en
partenariat aujourd'hui c'est
l'application nestor cette application
elle va vous aider pouvoir faire des
choses à votre place pour l'ensemble des
comptes bancaires
si je fais ce grossière que c'est parce
que elle a réuni tous vos comptes au
même endroit quand j'ai découvert ces
applications la première chose que je me
suis dit je vous y attends je vais
donner toutes mes coordonnées bancaires
des identifiants mais comme les accès à
mes comptes à une application évidemment
sachez que tout est ultra sécurisée qui
entre protection des données que tout
est chiffré que vous avez un code
personnalisé et c'est pas une société
inconnue qui a lancé ça puisque au
contraire c'est la naïve ce qui est
plutôt rassurant pour le premier point
que j'ai vu avec cette application c'est
le gain de temps est alors ceux qui me
connaissent sur cette chaîne savent
comme j'aime avoir du temps pour faire
autre chose cette appli elle te fait
gagner du temps parce que déjà tout est
réuni un seul et même endroit tous vos
comptes que ce soit les parcs du crédit
du compte courant d'une benne banques ou
de banques différentes et qu'on perd sur
des conjoints tout est au même endroit
et vous avez une vision globale dès le
départ
instantanément vous pouvez suivre les
seuls voir ce qui est passée ce qui va
encore passer ce qui à venir je trouve
ça extrêmement pratique surtout on a des
choses dans mon dépend qui divertit
banque extérieure
moi c'est le cas pour des comptes
épargne que j'ai ailleurs vous allez
recevoir et c'est vous qui paramétrer
tout ça au détail près des alertes et
des notifications de soldes par exemple
et apprécié votre seul descendre sur de
tels niveaux l'application peut prévenir
vous envoyer une alerte
vous pouvez aussi également avoir des
soldes d'argent qui rentre pour savoir
si votre salaire est versé donc sur vos
comptes quotidiennement sans jamais y
pense
puisque vous aurez automatisé en fait
tous asséné stork mais là ça prend son
sens c'est grâce aux catégories dont
toutes les dépenses et toutes les
entrées dont pourra être catégorisés
nestor fait déjà 90% du travail mais il
sait que telle ou telle chose correspond
à telle ou telle catégorie même si vous
pouvez le corriger si vous le souhaitez
vous allez aussi pouvoir très des
catégories spécifiques à vos dépenses ou
à votre rythme de vie à vous et toutes
les demandes de l'application ne connaît
pas et belle demande qu'à apprendre vous
allez pouvoir lui dire mais ça c'est
elle dépense de tels types de telles
catégories pour tel but
vous allez enfin savoir comme jamais
vous avez su quel pourcentage de votre
budget vous dépensez dans tel domaine
après à la deux autres avantages
l'application au delà qu'elles soient
gratuites d'ailleurs vous avez le lien
dans la description pour la télécharger
c'est gratuit son premier avantage là je
parle quand quelqu'un comme moi c'est
qu'elle prend aussi les comptes
professionnels et ça s'est super bien
d'avoir au même endroit pour moi d'un
seul coup d'oeil tous mes comptes
personnels et le compte de la société en
même temps mais surtout elle a une
option qui permet d'anticiper son solde
à 30 jours c'est à dire que leicester
par sa petite logique va analyser vos
comptes durant des mois est bien capable
de dire dans 30 jours exactement à
combien sera votre solde si vous suivez
votre rythme habituel
ça c'est disponible sur la version
d'histoire plus qu'il a est une version
payante de l'application mais vous avez
trois mois offert avec le code qui est
également dans la description ça vous
permettra de voir si vous voulez lire 17
options pas je la trouve pratique parce
que on à la synthèse des mois précédents
donc avant de passer aux quatre autres
astuces vous avez maintenant plus aucune
excuse pour ne plus faire vos comptes
parce que là vous avez même plus besoin
de faire concrètement puisqu'ils se font
eux mêmes via l'application et qu'elle
est gratuite encore une fois le lien est
dans la description en plus vous avez
les trois mois offert pour la version
1er de la 2e as tu sais qu'une fois que
vous allez gérer votre argent quotidien
via l'application que vous connaissez
vos secteurs de dépenses
vous allez maintenant de faire un truc
de ouf vous allez créer un compte
quelque part si possible dans une autre
banque et sur ce compte là vous allez
mettre 10% de tout ce qui rentre chez
vous de côté tout de suite
alors je sais de mettre de l'argent de
côté c'est pas simple c'est vraiment pas
simple pour personne mais surtout c'est
possible de faire et ça on verra ça dans
les autres astuces sur comment trouver
cet argent
tout ce que vous devez retenir c'est de
prendre ce réflexe là de mettre toujours
cet argent de côté et pourquoi pas je
vous le dirai
l'astuce d'après et en parallèle de sa
vous allez aussi ouvrir un compte ou sur
ce compte vous allez mettre 2 à 3 % de
ce que vous gagnez dessus la fonction de
ce conte et la fonction craquage ça vous
permettra dans votre vie de craquer
financièrement pour des trucs un petit
peu what the fuck ou qui n'ont aucun
besoin particulier ma de craquer à la
hauteur de votre budget tout simplement
nous aussi de pouvoir avoir cette
soupape ne pas faire attention
il est en ce moment tels que vous voyez
je suis dans une chambre d'hôtel au
mexique je prends mes vacances
si jamais durant les vacances il ya un
truc que je veux faire mais je sais que
c'est ridicule de faire ça ou d'acheter
ça c'est juste un craquage eh ben je
vais aller prendre dans ma cagnotte de 2
à 3% et du coup il a gagné 2 10% à quoi
sert et bcsa d'astuces numéro 3 la
cagnotte de l'epargne qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait épargnée c'est bien c'est une bonne
chose il faut le faire c'est dur et
parfois on est dans des situations
tellement précaire que c'est pas
possible
mais si on a juste un revenu modèle
c'est à dire qu'on s'en sort tous les
mois mais que c'est un petit peu dur
la fin de mois ça doit être possible
d'épargner pour cent ça me confiera
s'assure l'astuce 4 et 5 mais qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait de cet argent là après et
de la folle sortir de ce conte et fois
les l'investir le plus vite possible
alors pour optimiser son épargne va
falloir investir que ce soit dans des
sociétés ou en créant sa société cite
même vous avez un projet comme ça
productif ça peut être aussi en bourse
la bourse est pas un gros mot c'est pas
un truc inaccessible c'est un truc que
souvent on comprend pas c'est assez
simple à comprendre avec un compte titre
est assez peu d'argent sommes tous temps
on peut essayer d'investir en bourse ça
peut être aussi dans l'immobilier gandhi
l'immobilier on pense tout de suite à
des maisons ou des appartements ça peut
être un box a peut être un garage ya
plein de possibilités d'investir mais il
faut prendre en compte deux choses la
première chose c'est que
l'investissement qui rapporte 100 fois
plus ça n'existe porte ça s'appelle des
arnaques et la deuxième chose à
comprendre c'est que investir sans
risque ça n'existe pas non plus le
risque zéro n'existe jamais toute
manière si pourquoi il faut diversifier
vos investissements si vous prenez la
prendre votre épargne pour le mettre
tous au même endroit c'est peut-être pas
très judicieux mais c'est vraiment un
truc qu'il faut retenir épargnés c'est
bien par contre épargnées pour épargner
et ne jamais rien en faire il se passera
jamais rien en fait pas les taux
0 75% la quatrième as tu sais simplement
une phrase mais vous allez voir à la
puissance et elle va vous permettre
aussi de dégager de l'argent vous allez
pouvoir épargner puis investir plus tard
la phrase c'est nous ne sommes pas ce
que nous avons pas logique
c'est à dire qu'acheter un objet ou
faire une dépense quelle qu'elle soit ne
représentera pas qui vous êtes et ce que
vous n'êtes que vous êtes s'est défini
par ce que vous dites est ce que vous
faites si vous achetez un objet très
cool
cet objet cool vous leur en votre
possession mais c'est pas lui qui fera
en sorte que vous êtes cool c'est pas
lui qui fera que les autres vont
percevoir que vous êtes quelqu'un de
cool fois vous avez compris ce principe
là vous allez pouvoir vous posez la
question à chacun de vos dépenses
est ce que vraiment j'ai besoin de ça
c'est à dire est ce que ça va répondre à
des besoins vitaux est ce que ça va
améliorer mon confort est ce que ça
donnera un sens productifs est ce que ça
a une fonction dans ma vie où est ce que
je le veux seulement par désir parce que
j'ai la sensation qu'en achetant ça je
serais plus cela c'est la deuxième
réponse alors vous pouvez vous passer de
7 des pensions sincèrement et prendre
cet argent là pour le mettre de côté et
c'est comme ça que vous allez trouver
woods % en analysant sincèrement faut le
faire de manière honnête un sinon ça n'a
pas de sens les dépenses que vous avez
envie de faire ou les dépenses que vous
faites qui m'amène à la 5ème astuces
aussi qu'ils aient la patience c'est une
autre vertu à paris va être un cinquième
et astuces le patient j'ai bien
conscience mais vous allez vite
comprendre la patience ça permet de
faire des économies de tongs avec par
exemple le fait de prendre le temps
d'aller sur internet pour chercher les
codes promos ou des codes de réduction
sur le site essayer de faire baisser un
peu le prix ou de voir les frais de port
offerts par exemple la deuxième chose
c'est peut-être essayer de se faire
prêter ce qu'on veut acheter pour voir
déjà si ça nous convient vraiment vous
pouvez aussi penser à l'achat groupé qui
est toujours une bonne solution quand on
achète les choses groupe et on peut
toujours négocier quelque chose parce
qu'on prend un volume je prends un
exemple concret que je prends pas du
tout un exemple au hasard
je prends mon spectacle à l'olympia le
22 septembre 2018 ok les cheveux mon
spectacle mélange de mentalisme et
d'humour tout ça si vous êtes plusieurs
à vouloir venir si vous êtes un groupe
on va dire au dessus de 9 10
ça vaut le coup que vous contactiez
l'olympia pour voir s'ils peuvent pas
vous faire un tarif réduit pour le faire
les équipes moment il faut pas être
content que je dis ça
et pourtant c'est la vérité dès qu'il ya
un groupe les choses sont moins chers
donc pensez-y
et puis une autre chose que peut vous
amener la patience c'est le fait
d'attendre un petit peu parce que quand
on attend le prides on sait que panda
dans quelques semaines ou un mois ou un
an
alors c'est une nouveauté et donc les
prix vont chuter ça va être beaucoup
plus abordable en combinant tout ça vous
aurait pas de mal à trouver les 10 % et
surtout à mieux gérer votre argent
on passe enfin la question que tout le
monde se pose combien gagnent youtuber
sur youtube
c'est bien le seul métier où ah bah ça
suscite tellement de questions combien
la personne games jeux vérifier auprès
de mon boulanger personne lui a demandé
bon bref tout ça c'est assez amusant on
est tous conscients de ce jeu il ya
beaucoup de fantasmes beaucoup de
contre-vérités donc on va faire un truc
très simple je vais vous faire inscrire
de combien j'ai gagné le mois dernier
sur youtube alors accrochez vous bien
suspense
la somme est de 2800 $ non non c'est pas
en europe ça en dollars donc déjà on va
le convertir direct en europe ça fait de
1400 euros mais façon d'être et paypal
on va même pas les compter
on va commenter ce montant maintenant ce
montant qui à peu près pas la liste
parce que toute l'année c'est à peu près
ce que je gagne sauf que l'été c'est
avec beaucoup moins que des gens lever
et 5 % de mon network donc 120 euros en
moins sur cette base là qui reste
maintenant c'est une facture donc c'est
de l'argent qui arrive dans la société
de cette facture là il va falloir
enlever toutes les charges de la société
donc l'impôt sur les sociétés le cfe et
je vais être très gentil je vais enlever
seulement 23%
il nous reste donc 1755 euros mais de là
il va aussi falloir quand même que
j'enlève quelque chose qui est
obligatoire pour une activité comme la
mienne à savoir l'expert comptable qui
me coûte 150 euros par mois
et quand cette société il faut aussi des
assurances ça c'est obligatoire
donc je vais pas prendre l'assurance de
mon bureau et je veux pas prendre le
loyer non plus du bureau parce que je
pourrais faire tout ça depuis chez moi
j'ai juste enlever la responsabilité
civile professionnelle qui fait 110 au
et maintenant je fais un petit package
de plusieurs choses à savoir le
téléphone portable internet les timbres
tu vas acheter parfois les cartouches
d'encre ce genre de choses on va dire
que c'est un euro par m'en bats aussi je
suis sympa il nous reste donc une somme
qui va falloir divisée
art 2 si on veut que ça devienne bus à
berre parce que dans une société pour la
salariée dites vous que le salaire net
coûte à peu près x 2 à la société il
faut enlever les charges sociales
patronales et les charges salariales
plus en général un petit forfait de
prendre le comtat pour établir la fiche
de paie monsieur je ne compte pas c'est
cadeau donc on divise par deux la somme
pour savoir combien en est ivre s il me
reste donc 697 euros
surtout que ce n'est pas la réalité
puisque je vous ai dit moi et en plus il
faudrait rajouter l'investissement dans
les caméras les dépenses pour les vidéos
de bureaux l'électricité du bureau
l'assurance du poro et s'est trouvé ça
intéressant dans cette vidéo de faire
une transparence maximum pour que vous
ayez conscience combien une chaîne qui a
six cent mille abonnés génère de revenus
un petit peu mensuel et c'est comme ça
que vous allez peut-être prendre aussi
un peu de recul sur la vidéo qui parfois
ont plus de dix minutes et vous dites
quoi mais ça scandale c'est un contenu
gratuit
surtout et en plus de ça ça change pas
grand chose en fait
all you tube heures en face heureusement
mon vrai métier c'est pas youtube c'est
la scène c'est comme ça que je gagne ma
vie avec les spectacles et conférences
mais dites vous bien que les créateurs
que vous voyez sur les vidéos qui font
ce contenu qui faisait accessibles
gratuitement
ils le font forcément par passion parce
que celui qui veut faire ça pour gagner
de l'argent
ils se plantent nécessairement il se
plante il ya forcément à quelques cas
qui existe mais c'est pas possible enfin
j'en suis toujours suis un exemple très
concret et ensuite comme tous les
contenus gratuits que vous consommez
d'ailleurs assez régulièrement
vous posez d'ailleurs pas la question
comme comme sur youtube est belle et
financement ils passent en général par
de la publicité mais c'est le cas de
tous les magazines donc là la presse des
magazines les journaux la télévision
également et pas mal de sites internet
de blog où vous allez chercher des
informations pour tous ceux qui
regardent aussi des choses en streaming
complètement illégal c'est bourré
publicité aussi ne vous posez pas la
question et sauf que ça c'est légal
nouveau me fais des choses légales et il
ya aussi une manière en fait pour que ça
reste gratuit pour vous voilà je sais
pas si d'autres youtuber oseront en fait
pour faire des
comme ça de leurs revenus mais quoi
qu'il arrive dites vous que ce sera pas
tellement différent dans le
fonctionnement en moyenne il me reste à
peu près 500 euros par mois sur la
chaîne et ses 500 euros là me permettent
de développer un nouveau concept
d'acheter la nouvelle caméra par exemple
qui n'a servi à faire le calendrier de
l'avent que vous suivez là
quotidiennement enfin vous aviez pas là
c'est pas les investissements qui
manquent et après je sais qu'on peut
faire des tipis ou savoir deux choses
mais encore une fois c'est pas des
choses que j'ai envie de faire parce que
je ne considère pas du tube comme étant
un métier rémunérateurs c'est ça délire
de faire les vidéos c'est vraiment cool
de faire ça donc il n'y a pas nécessité
en fait à ce que vous fassiez des dons
par rapport à sa juste le système en
lui-même fonctionne en fait ils
fonctionnent pas très gros mais ça
fonctionne j'espère que vous aurez
apprécié cette initiative aussi les
astuces de la vidéo n'oubliez pas de
prendre le temps de télécharger
leicester c'est gratuit il ya mon code
pour avoir la version plus dure entre en
moi ça vaut le coup d'essayer et vous
verrez à quel point ça vous est utile ou
pas mais ça ça m'étonnerait
n'oubliez pas de laisser un laïcat la
vidéo ça aussi c'est gratuit ça ne coûte
rien du tout à faire
êtes vous abonnés c'est toujours aussi
gratuit même la cloche et gratuit et
bien tout ça pourquoi pas je vous donne
rendez vous demain pour la suite du
calendrier de l'avent sauf que la vidéo
sortira à 21h pour pas qu'elle se
chevauchent trop avec la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui
rendez vous demain donc à 21h
exceptionnellement ciao